今日はシュルツが終わってまだちょっと痛いんですけど
まず3冊ですよく見ると微妙に腫れてるのもんでまだちょっと痛いんですけど
まぁちょっと安静にしつつもうちょっと腫れがひくのなっておりますというわけで今日
はあんまり動く事も出来ないので雑学的な動画になります
皆さん自動車の免許を持つでしょうか俺は
6編だぜーそろそろ今年も終わってなんか卒業する人とかいると思うんですよ
あとなんか大学生で車の免許を取りたいなとか思ってる人いろいろいると思うんです
けども私
免許乗っており車の免許を持ってるって言葉もう車交通省いうのに関してもプロなんで
もう行った多少の音江南でまで交通ルールに傘全部頭に入っているわけでございま
で100点満点のテストがあってそれの何点だけも忘れたんですけど q 10が95
点ぐらい
ほ何点取らないと免許てもらえないんでそんな狭き門をくぐったもう伝説の自動車
プレイヤーというわけでまあそんなんだ免許持ってないそこの君たちのために車の運転
できる人ってどれくらいすごいのかっていうのちょっと教えてみたいと思います
アフにみたいなのがあるんでそれはちょっとやってみましょうこういういろいろあるん
ですよ
運転の基礎やが教式表示信号道路の走行方法
追い越し駐停車危険な状況での運転まあこういう感じで色々あるんですけどもまあまあ
70,000
僕にかかれば全部の問題満点で取ります運転の基礎知識からやってみましょう
本日料って人もいなければ
ランダムで10代選ばれるんでしょ
シャイ九度山始めました a
自家用の普通乗用自動車は原則2年ごとに検査を受け
整備寄せればならない
エットっ
っとそうですねこれは正しいです
2年毎にあるでステーキの経済がハイウェイーリリー車に乗車するときは周囲に
溶け込むためなるべくライフで嬉しいです
なきゃいけないじゃないですか自己流舞踊ペラペラは誤りですっなるべく明るい付で
運転するのが正しいとされております
覚えておきましょうこっちゃに乗ってる人多いと思うのでなるべく赤に服を着て
ください免許証を携帯することは忘れて自動車を運転すると名曲形態になる
こちら
はいこれは正しいですね
免許書をちゃんと常に持ってないとダメですうまま道路交通法における軽車両に分類さ
れる
馬はですねあれは
ん
んうまくなうなうなは軽車両だと思いますなんか道路上げてた気がするん
うまぁで誰も実は車でございます馬=包まればもですね
軽車両にされます
矢部います下駄やハイヒールを履いて4輪を運営するのは危険であるこれは危険ですね
ブレーキとかアクセルって足の裏でフルんでハイ
底のフーズ未見ですね運動靴が適しております車の所有者は自宅などから1km 以内
で駐車場を確保すればならない
その必要はないはず
ブー
ん
2キロ以内なんだあ
これもいいましたなぁ車に働く遠心力はカーブの半径が大きいほど大きいや日本語の
理解ができ
や小さいほど大きいんでこれはやってます
そうでそうれそうですねきゃってなかった方が不安ってなるんですよ
うーんうまかったらアーってなんですけど
キュッてもらったら森ヘッドタイヤで走るときタイヤと路面の摩擦抵抗中たくなるまた
ほんと日本語は難しいそうですね摩擦が小さい煮込まれにくくなるので
正しいですねはい
ok ですっけでよう前に古いなんかすり減ったタイヤで化すればするほどブレーキ役
を企画し運営する際は常に第二種免許が必要である
ハイあのタクシーを売ってるんじゃね別の人がいるんですよわぁ
客を乗せずにたくさんに徹すればいいがそうなんだ
何でも僕各種運転手じゃないんで多分大丈夫ですね駄目ですけどね数自動サルってどう
やって中にであるか違いますねっ
頑張ってづれづれづれだって普通自動車の中にも乗車天六にネスとかあるじゃんそれ
なんか全部住人なのが正しいと言われたらそれは僕は違うと思うわけですよ
問題声ですね
[音楽]
不合格でしたねまあ皆さんでわかると思うんですけどねっ
かんね自動車学校っていうか自動車の免許取る気の問題でちょっとねぇ
すごいんですよまあそれがいいとも悪いとも僕は言わないんですけどやってなってさあ
起こすくね動作点が住人じゃない時もありますからね
6人乗りの車もあるから
いやあああフォーレ日本は感銘を多分これ
総合演習の子が一番難しいんですよこれの者全力テストやっていきたいとおもいます
これでマンで撮っ
難しくねこれでマン手に取ったら俺は
プロドライバーエグゼ最大的最良1900kg の自動車が普通の祖である
[音楽]
うん最大積載業
これは違いますん
ana
7まだまだ踏切を通行するときは大工さん中一緒に行かなくている
注5
いや駄目です
そんなことはない大工さんに注意するのはいつでも大事なんでこれは違います
まだわからないでしょ前の自動車が原付を追い越そうとしているときは服も追い越して
はならない
前の車もちろんあたりまで背負ったねえ頭部に傷を受けた負傷者を救護する際は意識を
失わせないように揺らしたり話しかけたりすることが大事ですか
ヘッドねー
えっとね脳はねマジでダメだったら誰も話しかけたりすることもダメなんだよねー
はなく自動車これこれ自動車日常的な話じゃないかなこれ
脳に気がした人は no だからマジで危ないんだよって家でも大丈夫ですかっていう
心臓だった気がすんだよなそれ
正しいと思います
揺らすだめだそりゃ言い出しちゃダメなを持つのタクシーを運転する際を常にさっきの
問題ですね
リーマ
先行
運転中に眠気を感じたら窓を開けて環境してラジオ聞くと
規模でフレッシュさせるいや駄目ですが皆さんですこれダメなんですよちゃんと止まっ
て救急しなきゃダメなんです
ブーブー何でもいいからライト点けたり地震警戒船やてぃあーもう1もドロスチョン
ドゥ
ほとんどだっけなぁこう習ったんだよな
地震があったときにもうヤバいと思って車を置いて逃げなきゃいけないとにかかりつけ
た
たぶんそうだと思うはい
そうそう誰でもエンジンかけられるようにしないと例えば救急車来た時に動かせない
状態が車が運転できるようにして車を置いていくのが正しいらしいです展開するときの
合図の
じっと方向は薄っの時と一緒である
か違います一緒です深央季の真琴て信号となる場合がて下に従っ
はいそうでそれで辛抱がススメでございます
運転止めます
me
あっはぁ